right today the U.S Supreme Court
delivered what is a major victory for
fairness in college admissions and that
entire process 6-3 decision the court
struck down affirmative action ruling
that the use of race as a factor in
college admissions is unconstitutional
right one agrees
this after a group of Asian American
students filed a complaint against
Harvard and the University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill alleging that they
failed to employ race neutral admissions
practices now the majority opinion
delivered by Chief Justice John Roberts
said that any student quote must be
treated based on his or her experiences
as an individual uh not on the basis of
race highlighting the importance of this
case in a rare move now justices
Clarence Thomas and Sonia Sotomayor also
and actually read their opinions from
the bench now with Justice Thomas
declaring quote at all forms
discrimination based on race including
so-called affirmative action are
prohibited under the U.S Constitution
now a Harvard did in fact release a
statement following the decision
acknowledging that the Court ruled their
admissions policies did not comply with
the 14 18th Amendment the equal
protection clause in the Constitution
and the Civil Rights Act but Harvard
isn't actually totally backing down they
may still consider how race impacts
someone's life as part of their
application process and while the
University of North Carolina said
today's ruling was not the outcome they
had hoped for and well how did the left
handle this news today well about as
predictable as you would expect
president Joey Biden delivered yet
another very angry address he's been
very angry I do want to remind everybody
this is the guy that worked with the
former klansman Robert KKK Byrd is the
former Grand Puba of the clan and in the
70s they wanted to stop segregation in
public schools because Joe said his
words he didn't want public schools to
become racial jungles now anyway here's
Joe's uh you know he's full of his
struggles and ramblings and rantings and
mumbling and bumbling and some you
decide take a look
today the court once again walked away
from Decades of precedent and make as
the dissent has made clear the court has
effectively ended affirmative action in
college admissions
and I strongly strongly disagree with
the course decision the truth is we all
know it discrimination still exists in
America
discrimination still exists in America
today's decision does not change that
you know I know today's Court decision
is a severe disappointment to so many
people including me
but we cannot let the decision be a
permanent setback for the country now it
was not just Joe Biden who had a
meltdown over the Court's ruling the
left the mob the media made one
outlandish comment after another take a
look at this
the Supreme Court of the United States
is stomping on the dreams of our young
people this was just one remedy
affirmative action the only remedy to
the legacy of discrimination and
admissions in American higher education
only one remedy
and so here they've taken it away look
it's heartbreaking for our democracy our
democracy is stronger when our
leadership is diverse this is a very
serious uh change and from my point of
view a tragedy the headline for today is
access and opportunity denied I think uh
that this is tantamount to sticking a
dagger in our back what is it being
talked about enough is the harm this is
going to do for students not just black
and Latino students but white and Asian
American students is this leading to no
women in colleges soon who knows
really will be seriously anyway the
left's Meltdown didn't stop there
Michelle Obama releasing a statement
following the decision saying that she
is heartbroken and while Senate Majority
Leader Chuckie Schumer called it a quote
giant roadblock in our country's March
toward racial justice but as always the
left is completely out of touch with
everyday Americans take a look at your
screen according to a recent survey
conducted by Pew research well only 33
percent of Americans approve of colleges
giving consideration to race race and
ethnicity during admissions well just 20
percent of respondents said affirmative
action makes the college admissions
process more fair and according to a new
CBS News poll or conducted earlier in
June 70 percent of Americans agree with
today's ruling that the U.S Supreme
Court should not allow colleges to
consider race in admissions now now
while many on the left spent the day
whining complaining crying and screaming
and yelling and using lots of hyperbole
many Republicans actually celebrated
what was a victory for equity in college
admissions and frankly for our
constitution president Trump reacted on
true social today calling it a great day
for America Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis tweeted that the Supreme Court
correctly upheld the Constitution with
the decision so let me be clear this is
a major victory for fairness in college
admissions and the process of college
admissions and that is admitting
somebody
on their races not only by definition a
racist policy you're institutionalizing
discrimination creating what is a
blatantly unfair disadvantage for
millions of hard-working students all
across the country and today's decision
well that should put an end to that
although watch for Harvard to work and
end around and try and squirrely around
the new uh decision hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else